why do you write stories ah wow that is
a good question i would say that i write
stories primarily because i think i
enjoy storytelling i enjoy hearing
stories i enjoyed telling stories so I
think ultimately that just led me to
taking those stories that I would
verbalize and writing them on a piece of
paper but I think more than that to as I
get older you realize some things that
you are potentially good at and some
things that you might not be good at and
as I come to realize that I might not be
good at that many things I think that
writing is something that I can
potentially do that I enjoy and I know
that I wouldn't work in a capacity where
I had to show up and do the same thing
day in and day out so it's an
opportunity for me to wake up when I
want to wake up have a creative outlet
because creativity is incredibly
important to me I couldn't live without
it and express myself through story so
you know I I have a long line of
storytellers in my family no one that's
been published writers or works in the
film industry but people who when we get
together we like to enjoy you know good
food and good company and tell stories
and so I just always enjoyed it and I
think you know my friends would probably
tell you that if there's one thing I'm
maybe halfway known for its probably
telling a halfway decent story so it
just fit for me and I'm happy to
continue to pursue it you know for the
for the rest of my life
you